hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to don't escape for
this is the last day we have in the
wasteland and I apologize for the delay
in between these videos I've had a lot
that I needed to get done before I leave
to go home to LA but now we are back in
the thick of it and everything's locked
because we are still at the storm so
this is the last day this is the day
that we will ordinarily make our journey
over to the base and then we will go up
zoom into the sky and we will try not to
die whether we do or not is gonna be a
conundrum also I seem to be kind of low
on fuel and also I should make sure I
have everything that I need before I do
it I'll be right back
give me one second okay so I now got the
shovel the fuel which I'm gonna use to
refuel I've got the ID card which I'm
gonna need I have the gun I have the
silencer I oddly enough don't have the
scope but I think that's gonna be okay
so I'm gonna leave as many things as I
can in the truck bad as possible I know
I'm gonna need to gather more stuff
later and I'll save a spot for that
let's fuel this oh [ __ ] okay so we got
to go get fuel first that's gonna take
some time but it's best we do that
because we're gonna need to run around
anyway and if we go out there we'll be
out of fuel and we won't be able to do
that so this is go get fuel
okay we've fueled up and we have extra
fuel inside the tank we do want to
advantage we do want to if we do want to
investigate the abandoned burst SideReel
logo blah blah blah we already know all
this so there's gonna be something in
here that we need which is a key that
leads us to the lab correct lab 13 okay
but what I don't know is I don't know
the specific recipe that it wants just
yet so instead of going back and trying
to open that right away which is what I
did before I'm gonna go ahead down to
the place and see if there's something
down there that's going to be valuable
so I got the ID card I know I'm gonna
need that for the start of it anyway
oh wait I'm gonna do this and
the boy incus easy easy peasy okay let's
go see what's going on up here did we
get both cards did I bring both cards I
don't think I did so I'll have to pick
those up at the hideout along the way we
got that a metal plate that's good
duplexer so that still needs the
duplexer oddly enough okay I need to do
this again join kiss and Boing kiss okay
so there's a fuse box here and I
remember I need to go backwards for this
so let's just remember this properly
like and dedushka
dooshka okay good that's what I wanted
right elevator ready to go I don't want
to take the El puff just yet because I
want to open it first I wonder what
would happen if I what would happen if I
launch the ship before I even open the
canister cuz that would be something to
see what does that reject your map I
know I know I know I know I know I know
I know I know I know I know I know I
I know I know I know I know
remote control and an access card I
think on the remote control there's like
some kind of a battery open that up this
battery without it's useless some ID
card from Sartre saravana presentation
materials on my trip okay I already know
all that what about this piece of paper
and what does this contain okay that's
the formula okay that's the new formula
actually whose lung efficiency side
effects include itching and occasional
rashes long efficiency wait why would
you wet how's it gonna make my lungs
better how is that gonna even happen -
alright okay sure I guess that's
something for the oxygen thingamabob er
probably okay so I need to cut that
finger off to be able to get that but
let's let's just start assembling a
little collage of things that I need to
do before I come back here Wow yeah I
know I know it's a it's a real live
spaceship it really is yep yep yep yep
yep yep yep yep yep
we all know we all know okay let me uh
scan this card here let's skedaddle as
much as we can to try to get through
this I don't imagine it's gonna be all
that different from what it was before
at least with the thunderstorm that was
like an entirely different way of
solving these problems but with this is
still launching a spaceship so I'm
assuming that everything's gonna be fine
as a part of the bottom that seems to be
open or came loose I'll take it I hope
it wasn't important
yeah is that the duplexer okay that's
the duplexer
so uh no I'm gonna save the hats control
for last it's in case you never know I
want to see what happens when I'll see
silo has closed hull integrity check
failed air composition missing fuel
mixture selected few catalysts present
air supply lowered consider using air
saving pills yeah that makes sense
agnostic system is damaged please
perform a manual onboard inspection
definitely Diagnostics ok cool air
composition control all right so let's
see if I can do this there we go
I don't think it can be done any better
absolutely not I am perfection incarnate
so of course it couldn't be done any
better
alright let's see what this bad boys up
to we don't have a crack in the hull
here fuel catalyst console inlet for
catalyst fluid that will be injected
into the fuel tank that's wonderful
that's good so I can't go up until I fix
the elevator which means that I would
have to no I don't have to I can always
bring it back up it's gonna be a little
bit of a roundabout thing but I can
always bring it back up so I'm gonna do
exactly that I'll get it when I come
back just so I have more stuff oh let's
go ahead and put the duplexer on there
so I don't have to come back for that ok
so that's working again so the radar
screen should be up and going which
means that I can go back downstairs and
keep the location of the crash plane
what the what the plane on the ground
it's just crazy enough to be stupid wait
maybe I should actually maybe I should
actually go into the ship to see what it
needs the proper tool I could remove the
belt umm monkey wrench uh yeah yeah I
think what I should do is I should
definitely get this stamp oh I think I
need gas as well don't I put that there
oh it works nevermind it doesn't need
guessed that was something else that I
guess in here what have you got how does
it look
who knows we gotta we gotta actually
look at this so we're missing something
no nevermind okay so we got a tool box
glue gun and nothing interesting left in
the toolbox so we're missing the
auxilary air tanks so we need those uh
engine calibrator displays engine status
everything seems to be fine here so
that's good we don't need to have the
end in growl whoa I found some
spacesuits I didn't know that was there
before if I take them no I'll leave them
there we might
for later I mean I've got a red light on
that but maybe it's not important but
there is a crack here can't be good how
big I don't know palm-sized no idea
maybe it's just on the surface any
deeper we might be in trouble best case
scenario we'll lose oxygen worst case we
explode yeah it don't seem good well I
got a metal plate I don't know if I can
just
yeah I can't plop it on there yet so I'm
gonna drop the metal plate here cuz I
know I'm gonna need it well I guess I
can't drop in here probably cuz it sets
such a stupid incline and by stupid
incline I mean it's vertical okay and
then lithium hydroxide filter okay so we
need lithium hydroxide filter auxiliary
air tanks and then the welding thing so
that's what we know we need so we don't
need to bring anything else that would
be stupid right right okay so I'm gonna
leave that belt there for now and I'm
gonna finally go and open lab 13 go to
the crash plane get everything that we
need easy a glue gun we don't need that
yet batteries I think we can just
combine those the metal plate we can
keep in there the key I'll keep on me
and everything else is Gucci from there
okay let's go to the lab first cuz
that's the farthest and I still need to
grab something from the house the two
data discs and then I need to grab that
so I need to go to not the construction
site I need to go to sidereal plexus
then the construction site for the
welding kit which I know is there but I
don't have a glove yet for that so maybe
I should hit this airplane first just
because there might be a glove there
that I might possible let me save listen
let's save real quick let me let me save
let me say you know how I am with my
[ __ ] saving yeah let me go let me go
there see now I'm actually using my nog
a lot of people don't think I use my nog
but in fact I actually do use my nog
quite a bit and with my nog I remembered
to bring the shovel which is right here
which I can definitely use to shovel out
the sand dune 20 minutes holy hell
that's great okay cool so now we need
the manifesto I can't get a finger from
this guy and transponder flash long
enough alright so piece of paper it's
the manifest okay gaskets various sizes
volt meters navigation chips instant
noodles air tanks nuts and bolts wires
assorted so I need number five and
lithium hydroxide I'm not sure where to
get bad that might be in one of the
things in that room that I'm gonna open
once I get the thing
I don't think I need a navigation ship I
think I was actually good on that yeah I
think just the air tank right unless one
of these has like gloves in it because I
still don't have gloves to climb up the
rusty wire to get the welding kit but I
don't know okay hey I guess I guess we
gotta just go just number five all right
number five which one was number five
eight number five all right oh [ __ ] I
need the Kroeber let's trade out the
shovel for the Kroeber and put goose key
all right let's see what's inside air
tanks they're quite large and heavy okay
maybe I need a couple already have some
the ship is limited capacity anyway well
you know how it is why not just carry an
air tank with us because that would be
very helpful but no we're just gonna
we're gonna leave it up to chance okay
whatever all right so we're gonna go to
sidereal plexus let's go into lab 13
first hey no dead body here that's
awfully nice I mean that's just a
convenient nice thing to have in any
room that you wander into even if you've
been there already Oh creepy alright so
chemicals here chemicals here well let's
put these bad boys in here first and
then let's look at this bad boy okay
four red three black to blue four red
three black to blue let's see four red
four red three black to blue yeah yeah I
put some powder into the pill casings
okay four red three black to blue okay I
got him right seem to be very happy with
yourself what did you do I think these
pills will increase lung efficiency
which is a totally normal thing to say
you think are you really gonna digest an
unknown probably untested chemical not
just me you should do too hey alright
don't forget to share those pills then
yeah okay yeah yeah trust me I got three
but um hopefully that's enough
just in case that's it's weird that they
would only have three in the thing and
there's four of us so I'm just gonna
save just in case something horrible
happens which something bites I still
don't have gloves with which to get the
gosh-darn things well let me know at
least go get the finger cuz I there's
nothing I could have done to not get the
Finke first to open that other room cuz
that other room might have some
semblance of a something or other here
I need to reroute the power here Anton
okay it got it easy-peasy
did I just moonwalk out of there oh did
I I did bring the knife well maybe I'll
take a finger for good luck or a
fingerprint reader wasn't that bad the
body is pretty much mummified
nevertheless I don't want to do this
again I guess I could have done that at
any time then well I didn't think of
that already I guess for some reason I
thought you would have only known about
it at the juncture that you would have
needed to know about it and I already
have the data discs so don't worry about
that I am all good about data discs the
only thing I don't have is a welding kit
which I'm thinking now
just the way it is I'm probably gonna
have to go just get some gas let's pop
some stuff back in the cargo box I'll
keep the finger on me okay I gotta go
get fuel first that's definite well I
mean I already have fuel in here and
then I can just quickly pop out a refuel
here it doesn't take that much extra to
go here anyway so I guess it's not that
big a deal okay disk disk put the
formula away put the manifesto away I
don't think I'm gonna need it it at all
that if I need it I'll come back or I'll
reload to save you know whichever one is
easier and that's all I need okay on the
way okay insert gross detached human
finger into there I wonder if yeah that
worked nicely uh-huh okay weird device
that sounds promising a weird device
that also sounds promising and is that
all we have in here is that really it
it's to a lithium ion filter that's
something that I need but I still am
missing gloves with which to get hmm I
mean there's got to be some other puzzle
that I'm missing I mean there might be
gloves some wearing no that wouldn't
work at all that that's a stupid thing
that I was just about to scream out at
the top of my lungs I'm definitely not
about that
I left the tanks in the goddamn truck
yeah I'm an idiot okay hang on I'll be
back all right
err Thanks kaboosh all right we got air
whatever this is is apparently good we
just got to get that crack and then
that's it I think that's the only thing
we need so while I'm here just because I
want to and I think it'd be great for
some reason I am going to launch the
ship we can't launch until we find out
or do you want us to crash yes yes I do
yeah come
no that's I wanted to know come on no I
really wanted to do it yeah well that's
that's 20 minutes I guess I just wasted
but whatever fine I guess I can't see
it'll blow up
I forgot that there were other people
that were slightly more logical than I
am and didn't have that realization that
we could just save whenever we wanted
and I got a cycle that's actually 40
minute sideways cuz I got to do it take
it off put it back on again
what ever you Shh honestly just whatever
really you care that much about not
blowing up we could have busted through
that thing you don't know you don't know
what we could have done we could have
busted right through there it would have
been awesome you've been so rad I mean
we're gonna die anyway we're going to
the moon you think that's actually gonna
work no sorry Cody don't mean to burst
your bubble like this but we're all
gonna die okay so I need to go find a
way to get the welding kit I'm not 100%
sure how but we just gotta try so long
as we try I'll be pretty happy
okay welding kit I see you I can't reach
that hey can you guys give me a little
bit of a boost
hey Barry can you give me a little leg
up over there yeah hey your wife loved
you but you know I don't think you need
to know that I'm gonna cut my hands and
bleed to death if I try so there's gotta
be some other item that would have the
same function as protecting hands
because I don't think I've seen gloves
anywhere here like nowhere
I have not seen gloves anywhere unless
like the military left gloves behind
maybe yeah you don't think you don't
think oh look at that
[Laughter]
haha isn't a French laughing time to get
back the welding kit well that's good oh
[ __ ] we're out of gas now but the thing
I always fill this thing up or else we'd
be stranded we'd have to go walk and get
gas and that'd just be the worst Oh
walking huh all right let's do this I'm
gonna climb up you the hurry up we're
gonna get up there we're gonna get get
up there all right and then we're gonna
oh [ __ ] I didn't bring God really really
uh written I don't think I I think I
left that at the house yeah really yeah
yeah okay all right you know that's
please tell me it's in the truck it is
okay we're good for some reason in the
back of my brain I thought I needed it
here we are not wasting time great great
I know that wouldn't work I'm not trying
to combine the rope with the gloves I'm
trying to combine my genius with your
stupidity and you know the math just
doesn't check I add now what I'm trying
to do I'm trying to get down here no I
know don't pull it away no I don't put
it away come on ladies go down grab the
thing go up and then now we can do the
going now go we may do we're all good
here everything's good don't worry about
a thing everything's good everything's
great okay it's a welding kit what kind
of fuel did it it was electric right I
think that's what it was together with a
welding mask I think but just in case
I'm gonna go get in some more gas at the
gas station
just in case it's like needs some gas
generator [ __ ] going on which if did
it would need like a extension cord
right didn't it I don't remember it ever
needing that that doesn't ring a bell it
has been a while admittedly admittedly
it has been a little bit of a spell
since last time I was doing those
actions but it does not ring a bell it
may have been a spell but it don't ring
no bell you know what I mean okay anyway
I'll be back okay let's see if this is
gonna work welding kit oh it somehow
works now I just didn't need some
material to weld okay and okay and there
we go I think that is all we needed
correct
I am pretty sure if I am not sure than I
am an idiot and if I am an idiot my name
ain't markiplier so let's take these
pills
so before I forget here take one right
before we lift off ha what take one
before we lift off you sound like a drug
dealer using some weird slang Hey
very funny we're all so funny here it's
special pills you want me to take one
normally if someone would tell me to
take a pill that's gonna help me get to
the moon hey kid you put some weird
drugs here take this what's that
medicine I'm not feeling sick I know but
this will all be breathe in the
spaceship will I be able to breathe in
space no not really just keep this pill
and swallow it right before you launch
okay and we're good to go I think we
barely have enough fuel we have to limit
our weight you seem to be carrying a lot
of stuff oh that's right take only
things that weigh say one kilogram in
total 1 kilogram fine okay that's right
I forgot I needed to do that so I need
to drop all my [ __ ] right here we're
gonna drop the hammer we're gonna drop
the wrench we're gonna drop the squeal
you drive we're gonna drop the crib or
the calibrator the rocks sad to say the
rocks gotta go and then bada bing bada
boom looks like we got everything we
need okay final save before the very
bitter end it's just a big one there's
the Mamba Jamba Jays damage ohm bah bah
humbugs get rid of the welding kit
oh whoops all right well good call I
guess you're not gonna make me crash so
whatever all right it weighs a ton it
doesn't weigh a ton but it weighs a lot
weighs quite a lot actually
all right let's do this now we're ready
ready when you are
oh yeah oh the knife I'm gonna arm
myself with a knife hills okay
Bobo's skate burn so fun all right Barry
and Cody it's truly a miracle to have
them both here a faint memory from
another life echoed in your head ah
there we go
let me just give this for you we go up
into sky Oh Sarge traveled west the old
squad raised their heads engaged into
the sky tracing the bright light would
you look at that kid actually did it
good luck with whatever you find there
last bottle of whiskey Oh default
settings have been corrupted you were
forced to create the air composition
yourself the composition was perfect the
air results reserve sustain you for a
long time fresh lithium hydroxide filter
into the loo
ladies or the carbon hey maybe animal
you saw a reserve air contains an
shuttle when the regular air and low the
reserves kicked in providing you the
life-saving oxygen but thing you notice
the fix the crack of the hall you
prepared some pills long efficiency and
it reduced the amount of air you need
during the flight Kate took one pill
berry a pill Cody a pill and I took a
pill yay from there was surprisingly
sure way to the moon
Kate flew his ship towards the lunar
base mmm there she is moderately less
impressive than the last time because
I've already seen it but still breath
taking all right you guys can stop
applauding now I know that whenever I
tell a great joke you just start
clapping at random at home and I
understand that I can feel it
but seriously you need to calm down
you're disturbing your parents come on
here's disturbing your neighbors your
friends everybody you're clapping and
applause and shouting of upheaval roars
applause is just it's too much right now
come on I'm gonna have a better one
immediately after this so just you hold
it there you know what a waste it all in
the first one there's a lot more coming
I am hilarious anyway are we dead no
okay all right then I mean I don't know
why I sound so disappointed about that
but I guess that's fine all right let's
get the I should check with everyone
before ok whatever code are you okay are
you alive yeah yeah hey bear are you
hurt yeah yeah yeah okay cat Kate
Katherine whatever whatever your name is
Lu you hurt okay space shoots couscous
all right now let's get you out of here
decompression complete oh there we go
oh hell yeah I still wish I could wander
around on the moon that'd be that'd be
pretty cool okay
airlock manual manual override any day
now thank you all right uh it's a puzzle
it's actually like the SideReel logo I
think is the whole deal with this yeah
we go easy peasy
I don't know I made that so complicated
if someone was outside and had no air
and they were like 3 seconds away from
death I think they'd probably not be too
happy about that
we're gonna go inspect this thing we've
got the memory boost cards both of them
which is very good access card oh good
thing I brought this
oh good thing
oh [ __ ] oh that's right never mind I
thought the same thing before but as it
just so happens to turn out the way that
it turns just so happens the table turns
that there's a card over here why are
the people here you said they all left
they went they keep hopping over two
different dimensions sorry I know all
this I don't need to ask you about this
I'm good I'm good I'm good I'm good I'm
good I'm good I know realm of dreams
yeah real weird huh let's get this card
we don't have a lot of time we're gonna
slam ooh there she goes goodbye we're
gonna slam this bad boy into here there
we go all right now we're talking okay
constant lets you access sleeper pods
once you have it you'll be able to open
and yep do it
access granted I've done all I had to do
here time to move on all right here we
go yeah cuz when you think about it if
you if you if you they're in some takes
of like the the multiverse theory like
there are literally an infinite number
of possibilities so like with an
infinite number of possibility is so
hard to wrap your head around what
infinite could possibly mean because
infinite is legitimately infinite it
it's just beyond infinite it's it's like
so there there would be so many
different varieties universe that every
single possible permutation of the
slightest change is different but that
also leaves an infinite number that are
nearly exactly the same we're the only
change is instead of saying butthole I
said plethora at a certain juncture in
one of my sentences and that's it
that's the only difference because
infinite is so stupid to think about
it's it's impossible to wrap your head
around Oh nah nah nah nah check that
again maybe it was a glitch that's no
good
but excute wait what's a phase country
already know what this is well I mean I
don't remember what it was but we all
know you know what I know what a phase
controller is and that means that in
this game every single choice you make
whether you make it there or not is a
universe where that eventualities and
yet everything else in the entire world
that pertains to that reality is also
the same just because infinite is
infinite and it's like every single
moment of every single possible nuance
of reality changes and that also means
there's an infinite number of ranges
where we don't exist at all humanity
doesn't exist that did that is an entire
permutation of is because infinite means
freakin infinite all right let's do this
all right I'm slamming these babies in
here all right insert drive beat
computer reads its program will not
replace the phase controller however it
will increase your memory transfer
that's good I hope this is gonna make
things better what about this mem bust
I've inserted member striving to drive a
the computer reads it all right men
boosted this was not prevents memory
loss but will let you carry over more
memories in case of emergency merge
interesting so neither of them fix it I
have a memory of inserting a single disk
into this console in previous life maybe
now with both discs in place things are
gonna be ok
I mean maybe I've inserted the 2 special
discs into the console what disc one was
labeled memory boosting the other was
phase controller light I found them at
the sidereal Plexus office and I know
they're gonna help because I remember
using one disk in my previous life
wait what you actually remember being
here vaguely like a dream if one this
caused this two of them might actually
boost the system enough for us to
survive to end this how many loops do
you remember I'm sure about one then
again I had prophetic dreams in the
previous life too so I guess we've been
through a lot and hopefully this is the
last one let's do it then let's do it
the time to sleep right or should I go
first it's ok remember to turn the
lights off I promise you won't do
anything stupid have I ever done
anything stupid yeah you're funny you're
nice
hey Barry Kate sorry if I was mean to
you oh it's ok that's how you roll right
I know you're a good person Kate even if
you don't want the world to know see you
around bye big man hey Cody
um never change ok ok see you soon good
night Kate
alright David so here we are at the end
of the road or is it the beginning I
wouldn't have made it here if it wasn't
for you are you getting emotional now I
think I've spent too much time with you
where do you hope to wake up in a bed in
a world where they have a moon and
lattes of that's what happens me too
I did until we meet again just don't
point your gun at me when we do OK can't
promise that hey I make the jokes that
lead to raucous applause here alright
Cody I I think it's time to sleep Cody I
don't want to sleep I know but we all
have to I won't be able to sleep now I'm
too scared this machine will help you
come on don't be scared what will happen
we go i I don't know but it's gonna be
alright
sleep well kid you to Barry David I
don't want to be alone again you won't
be where ever you wake up I'll find you
promise promise
hey Barry sorry about you dying last
time Maggie loved you huh of course she
did
and I loved her why on earth would you
bring that up now just I don't know I I
don't think she blames you for anything
that happened I don't want to talk about
it David we have things to do
I don't like this idea David I know what
you want me to say I don't like it be
honest I have no idea if this does
anything or if we're just being
delusional
nothing lose right we came this far
might as well give it a shot
want me to go first yeah it's okay you
seem to be the one who knows which
buttons to press hey David
yeah you say we can find ourselves
anywhere in any world that's how I
understand it you think you think I'll
see you Maggie my wife I don't know bear
but I think there's a chance you will
say hello to her for me
sure thing David sure thing it's so sad
but also like so nice in a weird way
like it's bizarre it's both right it's
sad because we've been through this
before and we've been looping and we've
become trapped and Barry was dead in the
last one and now he's alive and Maggie's
still dead it's it's just a very bizarre
situation you were where you wanted Kate
let's hope you're right about all this
sleep well little prince you've earned
some rest buddy and now it's time for me
let me just double-check that
everything's good here all right here we
go
are you sure you want I mean when you
say it like that I just got to make sure
everything's doochie over this way I
don't know maybe I should check it out
maybe I should try to go out yeah side
that'd be pretty cool no there's nothing
else to do what else could you do right
I I tried this last time where I was
just like maybe there's something but
now there's nothing else to do
it's just get in this pot and go to
sleep and wonder where you're gonna end
up what time did this happen last time
air main power oh that's right it did
happen last time because they were like
oh god I make it a crises all right take
a look
necessary system powerses communication
and procedures we're closed and prey
closed and prey
I'll open it again do it oh there we go
I'm out of here baby
yes oh boy kaboom all right let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go
no time to lollygag better get to
sleepy-weepy all right and yes I'm in
I'm not asleep yet oh god damn my
inability to sleep fast and there we go
the family an escape for the
achievements iron lunar drilling
cancelled latte there's a moon and
lattes
Wow adoption permit
Oh
Maggie's live Cody's gonna have a I
don't know Cody was at all
you know for a second there I thought it
was gonna toss me back again but oh oh
oh so I I loved it I loved it so much I
loved it so much man now I feel bad that
I I took so long to play the last
episode of it and it was it was it
wasn't a choice of mine I guess I
literally was so busy that I couldn't
dedicate the long time that it takes to
record this episode with filming and
it's like ah it was so beautiful it was
so beautiful I loved that I loved it
every part of it the story was great it
was so mind-bending and it was just so
fun like it was just a fun experience it
was fun to click around and yeah I got
frustrated of course I got frustrated
I'm an idiot so I and I don't think
things through but it's that was so fun
and the story is so satisfying it's so
weird to think about this constant
never-ending cycle of death and rebirth
across an infinite number of universes
just to get to the point where you kind
of make it you know just to get that one
moment where you can actually save one
of these worlds where you're only by
your intervention is the next world that
you're gonna be in not gonna be
destroyed it's such a beautiful story
I loved that I loved the custom game
custom oh boy wait both disks used but
you can still what poison poisonous gas
what really what the hell that's so cool
that is so cool
freezing wave heat wave that's so cool I
really love that that is super fun I'm
really happy about that one that one was
almost so much fun I just want to see
what happens if Oh
if you have both discs there's gotta be
like some deeper level some even deeper
level to use both discs but it's only a
reward for the custom game so probably
not story-wise satisfying but you know
you know what I mean like it's it's good
[ __ ] that's no good um beautiful he's a
really beautiful game Phil is something
more in that dream something sad
important is different I'm gonna find
out what yeah it's it's it's just it's
so pretty
I love it this was obviously a work of
passion this was obviously a work of art
from a developer that I really like and
they obviously put their heart and soul
into this so if you want to play this
game for yourself and you haven't gotten
it already please do support the
developer on this one script well there
deserves that all the team that worked
on it deserves that kind of support it
is a great game it is a wonderful game
that really has passion to do it
imagination
exploration kind of its discovery this
replayability the sense of randomness to
it it's really cool and I'm so glad that
I got the chance to play it so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to get it for yourself it is in the
description below two links to the steam
page just check it out throw some words
of encouragement towards script welder
this is a great game and I had fun every
second of the way so thank you everybody
so much for watching if you want to
check out the other
don't escapes because this is the fourth
in the don't escape series there's don't
escape 1 2 & 3 and also script well
burners deep sleep series which also
ties into this and helps explain that
dream world they were talking about and
also goes in more of SideReel plexus but
kind of it's so cool to see how the
origins of that kind of storyline bleeds
all the way through to this game here
and connects everything is some nice
connective tissue so check that out all
links in the description thank you
everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
[Music]